right now we turn to the mercedes-benz
vans phone line and find the head coach
of uh one of the top quarterbacks
available just draft if not the top
prospect at the quarterback position in
this draft in this quarterback driven
league pat narduzzi of pittsburgh
football here on the rich eisen show how
you doing coach
i'm doing good rich thanks for having me
on today really appreciate you you
joining me how how is everything uh pro
day everything for you what's going on
everything's going great here pittsburgh
got beautiful weather it's in the 40s so
it's a beautiful day in pittsburgh
finished practice 11 have a scrimmage
number 12 in spring ball and then pro
day was outstanding kenny pickett i
think i heard you say
he's you know possibly one of the best
quarterbacks he is the best quarterback
there's no question about it okay so
let's just dive into this when when did
you first see him meet him recruit him
walk me through that process coach oh
gosh richard was a long time ago man i'm
getting old uh but you know obviously
out of high school coming from ocean
township high school in new jersey and
you know we recruited him out of out of
obviously high school he wasn't a
transfer portal guy or a grad transfer
uh he's a guy that we we thought had a
ton of talent was originally committed
to temple and kind of we beat temple on
north carolina and
the tar heels came in late trying to get
them when we didn't have a quarterback
coach or offense coordinator we were
able to hold on to him and
really in his freshman year
you know he played the last four games
of the season season out of need our
starter got hurt he was really a scout
team quarterback and we brought him up
and started getting him reps because we
knew he was the future and
uh he ended up helping us in his only
start the last game of the season
against miami beat number two miami at
home here at heinz field
give me a good story about his uh
demeanor and huddle locker room
leadership what do you got for me on
that coach oh rich he's he's a
phenomenal leader he's been a two-time
captain for us and and probably you know
at the quarterback position you know you
need a guy that's you know going to lead
your football team uh not only did he
lead our offense he led our football
team i mean he was he was the the guy
uh i think that the offense and the
defense fed off his leadership but uh
you know he was just a you know a guy
that you know constantly you know uh led
this football team it wasn't so many
words and i think sometimes
you know he led by leadership but uh he
he's not a rah-rah guy he's a serious
business type leader
and just you know takes just a few words
nobody wants to hear you know long
speech out of a leader especially you
know especially uh you know a player uh
they certainly don't want to hear it out
of a coach but you know about every
halftime this year he got him better you
know like his halftime deal was after i
got done talking was hey whatever it
takes you know whatever it takes to get
it done guys let's get it done and and
uh and our team fed off of him so you
would speak and then he would speak at
halftime
yeah at halftime just right before we
you know would bring them up and break
them down before we leave for the uh for
you know for the third quarter
uh you know i always just kind of got
them all locked in but then kenny was
going to get the last word in which was
awesome yeah so not like some uh gene
hackman hoosier speech just a quick word
before you go back on the floor
no doubt about it okay and so um let's
let's get into um everything you know
the main topic of discussion with him
which i'm sure for a defensive coach
like you a hard-nosed long-time coach
like you uh the words hand size might
just make your eyes roll but that is the
conversation i'm sorry i'm i'm i'm just
walking through the front door here but
also understand how silly it might sound
but in the nfl you know you parse every
single
uh inch or every eighth of an inch like
you know his hand size growing between
the kanban and his prote so what what
what can you tell me about that
storyline here you know again i think it
is you know uh something everybody's
looking at talking about as far as the
media goes but rich there's not one nfl
head coach
uh which we had a few of them at our pro
day uh not one scout uh assistant coach
quarterback coaches mentioned one word
about it so i think it's
all uh you know
you know all hot topic i guess but uh
you know i've never ever you know in
five years coaching him
um ever go you know god you got small
hands man
it was never a topic
and they didn't become a topic because
it was never an issue on game day i mean
if he was a guy that fumbled the ball a
lot then you might go hey let me measure
your hands but uh
uh i've never noticed that it really it
comes down i think he's got a normal
sized head but you know he doesn't his
thumb doesn't always reach
like it doesn't stretch out you know uh
which i've never noticed you know again
five years with him recruiting him it
was never
something like hey there's something
wrong maybe we need to you know get
surgery on his thumb or something i mean
it's uh the guy's a phenomenal
quarterback and and uh he's got ball
skills and
um again just you know knows how to
throw football well i guess it's all
hand or larger what does it matter yeah
i was like part of the receiver that's
right
i don't mean to talk over you but i
guess um the the idea though is
everything gets parsed out in the nfl
and that uh you take a look at the
history of the first round and
quarterbacks at the position michael
vick was the last first round draft
choice who had a hand
the same size as kenny pickett and so
it's been a long time because teams just
think about that and just think about
how uh that might affect certainly if
you're in cold weather but as you just
mentioned it's a 40 degree day on april
1st in pittsburgh so he's done this
before you've never at any point in time
saw something on the field or and again
you're a defensive minded coach so you
know what you can attack of an
opponent's weakness if that is such a
thing you never once saw
a moment
whenever never there's not one time and
again i'm not just talking game days you
know where you
um you know where you you know you you
know everybody sees it um i'm talking
practice and you know how many balls
he's thrown in practice and how many
practices he had
through his five-year career pit i mean
never once from his early days on scout
team never once did you go why does he
fumble the ball so much he doesn't
fumble the ball
and he doesn't put the ball on the
ground and he knows the ball is the
program and the team and and uh and
again that's not an issue it's not an
issue at all pat narduzzi head football
coach university of pittsburgh here on
the rich eisen show so who's the one who
taught him the fake slide and keep
running who's the one who taught him
that one
you know what uh that's it's funny uh
you can go check my twitter probably
about a week and a half maybe two weeks
after that acc championship game where
we beat wake forest
um and kenny had the famous fake slide
that now the ncaa has made a rule that
you can't do which i don't think you'll
ever see it again
um kind of you know funny that they'd
even do it but obviously it was not
taught i wish we as coaches were that
smart to teach it and practice it and
drill it and i wish i could show you you
know drill tape and an individual period
where quarterbacks were were practicing
i think if he practiced it he probably
would have fell over
uh like most guys would have but i think
it was an instinctual thing i should say
i think it is i know it was just his
instincts and
um and so i had one of our gas go back
and look at all our quarterback slides
that we defended again as you mentioned
rich i'm a defensive guy yes
and uh and we're pretty aggressive when
we're you know quarterbacks can slide
but we're gonna you know they go down
we're gonna go over top of them we're
not gonna go oh i think he's gonna slide
it looks like he's gonna slide and i'm
gonna stop five yards before i get to
him so i think as he started running he
saw
the defenders you know two or three of
them just kind of almost stopped five
yards away
um that uh you know he kind of said i'm
gonna slide and be safe here and then he
said wait they aren't coming after me
and i'm gonna take off and go and that's
what he did and uh to me it's great
instincts by a quarterback that's
incredible presence of mind what what do
you say to him
when he comes back to the sideline
what what is that nice play kenny
congratulations you know i mean right
it's not like he went down too low i
mean it was just a heck of a play i mean
you just talk about that's what you want
i mean you don't have to teach someone
to do something like that or i mean
that's what he's got you know we talked
about his leadership and and everybody
sees how he throws the ball and how
accurate he is i mean he's going to put
the ball like you have to in the nfl
right where it needs to be on the
outside number the inside number but you
know you want a guy's got instincts and
uh that just kind of shows you kind of
the moxie he's got well i got to tell
you you know
doing the combine on nfl network sitting
in the booth getting watching him get
ready for his 40-yard dash i was hoping
like right around the 20 or 25 he would
fake
slide and keep running like show it one
more time in the 40 that would have been
just next level yeah his agent would
have been real happy about it for sure
he's got instincts he's a really smart
kid uh he studies the game and
um you know he he's a lot smarter than
that that's for sure pat norduzi here on
the rich eisen show a couple more
minutes left with the pittsburgh
panthers head coach so um the
conversation about where pickett may go
uh the steelers sitting there at 20th
overall and the number of times i've
heard also
uh well i share a building and i i know
i i you know in many years covering
steelers thursday night football games
for nfl network uh we would set up shop
in the pittsburgh panthers locker room
that's where we would be uh as a group
so you're right there the question is is
how
how real is that though that well the
steelers are right there and so normally
they're going to see him and they're
going to know him you know james connor
obviously is another example of how the
pipeline just stays put right there how
much contact do you have with the
steelers just by because there's close
proximity
we have a lot
you know
again you know we have it's a big
building and you know they've got half
of the building we've got half of the
building so we actually don't share like
locker rooms here in the building just
like we don't share locker rooms at
heinz field
uh there there's a con a kind of contact
i mean tom will come strolling over to
my office and we see each other on the
field when you know when we're both
practicing at the same time or
um or just just in the weight room i
mean he'll see him pop in he's just a
you know as you know mike tomlin is one
of the
best people persons around he's going to
talk to everybody and he'll be out at
our practices i mean my very first
spring here back in 2015 i'm you know
we're practicing all sudden i see him
standing hanging out with our players on
the sidelines so
uh he's he's around quite a bit and he
obviously got a bit very busy job but
he's a he's a football guy and he loves
watching our guy so he knows our guys
better than anybody um you know kevin
colbert knows our guys better than
everybody they're they're you know they
can look out the window or out our patio
here watch practice so that one of the
uh they're one of the 32 teams or the
only one of 32 teams that doesn't have
to ask you uh about a prospect coming
from your program and how they practice
they literally have seen it it's what
you're saying they have seen it
there's times while we're practicing or
they're they're doing their walk
throughs that coach tom will be bound
with watching our guys and
and uh i always say evaluating what
we're doing and how we're doing it and
it's always good to have another
incredible head coach
peeking at your practices and giving you
tips and that's getting tips from the
steelers in their practice well sure um
all right well coach i truly do
appreciate the time and i am mandated to
say you know the photographs that we've
popped up of you on television uh over
the last um several minutes uh you look
good in uh yellow and blue i'll be very
honest with you you know you look good i
don't i didn't use maze but uh the color
scheme is really good compared to the
color you previously wore before no
doubt about it i'm glad you didn't use
that word maze because i was green for a
while over there in the state of
michigan i know you're a michigan grad
so we you know we don't like that maze
color over here in pittsburgh well i
mean it's maize-ish what you're wearing
i mean you do have that i mean the tie
that you wear on your in your in your
headshot it does look a little close to
that so
you know but uh i'm sure you you enjoyed
your time there for darn shore up in
east london we had we had a good time in
the state of michigan that's for sure
did you did you ever hang with izzo at
any point in time an arduino summit yeah
two italians i mean live probably half a
mile away in the same subdivision so
coach izzo is the best he is he's one of
my favorite people hey coach thanks for
the time greatly appreciated good luck
oh before i let you go pound the table
who else from your i know i just spent
time on your your quarterback anybody
else you want to mention here before the
draft that comes up in about 27 days
here we've got a few guys rich uh we've
got a few guys you know i think we had
the only snapper at the combine cow out
of midas is a is a guy then damari
mathis one of our corners uh went to the
combine ran a 4-3-9 and
again i think he
brought jumped 11 foot and had a 43.5
inch vertical so one of the best
athletes and quarters that i've ever
coached and i had two first-rounders at
michigan state with our quest bernard
and trey wayne's this guy's one of those
guys uh he's a competitor he knows how
to press and uh we press all the time so
those are the top three guys that with
the you know the combine that you may
have seen there and obviously in the
senior bowl as well what's your long
snapper's hand size coach do you know
that you know what he's got he's it's a
four and a half inch but he snaps that
ball back there that's awesome
coach thanks for the time really do
appreciate it good luck rich thanks
you bet anytime thank you that's pat
narduzzi everybody head coach of
pittsburgh football right here i knew it
old-school defensive minded coach
hand-sized my ass is really what he
really wants to say
did you see the kid play
didn't he wind up on the uh heisman
trophy podium yeah he did
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here